okay so a Yaya Yaya once another skin he
was developed to be higher and smarter
creatures and we developed that so I
don't see why not
in principle it's just that the brain
remains such a mystery to us we don't
really have a good explanation for
consciousness much less what's going on
in your brain for it to become
intelligent right we know what can make
you really not intelligent okay socially
good almost any chemical influence on
the brain makes you sort of less capable
than other than no influence on the
brain okay when do things like alcohol
and drugs and things that people people
do under those influences that's not
when you want to write down the rocket
formula right so so in this I would say
there could be a day where we find out
that these neural synapses are your
analytic Center and this is where your
math Center is and this is where your
artistic Center is and I want to be a
better artist well stimulate that or
rebuild this I don't see anything in
principle from standing in the way of
that ultimately being discovered one day
unless intelligence is so complex soap
is so distributed in all the neural
synapses that it's hard to just point to
it we can't can't locate localize it
localize it it could be something much
more intricate than how I'm making it
sound at this moment but sure you'd want
it you'd want that to happen and then
there's all we can become better
shepherds of our own fate because
there's also the integration of
technology into the human brain that may
be the next evolution of who we become
why you have to put it in the brain just
leave it out here all right no I ain't
come over my brain all right you're
right stop messing with my brain stay on
the phone damn right people stay on the
phone you say one day we'll plug the USB
into your neck and I'm saying this is
kind of already that right right but
it's not plugged into my neck right and
get knowledge from the world all right
here Oh in the palm of your hand
I got dick alone if you like this please
remember everything that we do can be
found commercial free plus exclusive
original content all on starts off all
access com